did you struggle with then your career
of people like wanting to be like you're
this character and you're like hey like
I want to also work on myself I did wait
until Pitch Perfect seemed like it was
over that Amy
I'm an open book
I mean for God's sake you guys have got
me fat ain't me I couldn't you I
couldn't lose a massive amount of weight
um because I was in the contracts for
that movie Rebel Wilson claims being in
the Pitch Perfect films meant putting
her health goals on hold my best self is
like definitely someone who's living a
healthy lifestyle
um which is both like physically and
mentally Rebel's been very open about
her health Journey for years this year
I'm concentrating on health the
Australian actress lost 77 pounds during
her self-proclaimed year of health and
now on the call her daddy podcast Rebel
says it would have happened a lot sooner
if it wasn't for her contract for the
Pitch Perfect Trilogy I did wait until
Pitch Perfect seemed like it was over I
couldn't I couldn't lose a massive
amount of weight because I was in the
contracts for that movie you can't lose
I think it's more than not more than 10
pounds or it's a real gain more than 10
pounds yeah you have to kind of stay at
the weights like in your contract
um and but I'd been thinking for a while
like oh I wanted to get healthier
and I was stereotyped
um in playing that fat funny friend yeah
Rebels talking about her breakout role
as Fat Amy in the 2012 musical comedy
[Applause]
[Music]
this movie was just so much fun like it
was kind of like we were all in college
just like having a good time we play a
group in the movie and but we're all
such a unit now in real life which is
really good she says taking the gig was
a no-brainer because she and the
character had a lot in common I was like
nah Fat Amy I think is like the best
character in the whole movie like of
course I'd love to play it and um and so
and it really didn't offend we called we
had the best fun on Pitch Perfect movies
and to me like it was just awesome to
play her because she's just so confident
and ballsy and and I have like part of
it is me Rebels time as Amy came to an
end in 2017 with Pitch Perfect 3 but
fans are forever Holding Out for more
why cardio yeah no don't put me down for
cardio Edie spoke with Rebels co-star
Anna Kendrick in September and she
didn't totally shut down the idea of
doing a fourth are you interested do you
feel like Becca has more story to tell
would you do a fourth I think we love
each other so much and you know I think
we would probably make 16. but
um yeah of course that's not our
decision as for Rebel she's busy wearing
many hats these days the most recent
title she's added mom to a little girl
named Royce how has motherhood changed
you personally a lot like it changes
your life
um and but I feel like I was in such a
place like ready and uh and I've been
trying for a few years to have a baby
and so like she's just my little miracle
Little Rosie and she's just so cute
[Music]
foreign